pour faut que les parents ne se
décourage pas fait un seul enfant a
refusé une fois deux fois en arène c'est
le repas le plus important de la journée
mais il est souvent difficile de le
faire entendre aux enfants dans le cadre
de la quinzaine de la nutrition à
trappes de nombreux ateliers autour de
l'équilibré alimentaire était programmée
aujourd'hui les parents apprennent
comment faire prendre aux enfants
un vrai petit déjeuner ce qui est
important c'est déjà de s'hydrater boire
de l'eau ou un jus de fruit ou vers de
l'ertt et une tisane et d'avoir un
apport en sucre
donc on va apporter avec les féculents
oui j'ai appris des choses vraiment
prendre en compte
chacun chaque parole et drame on se dira
qu' il n'y a pas de mode d'emploi en
fait on enfin on accompagne on n'est pas
là forcément pour apporter la solution
aux parents et à l'enfant parce qu'au
final faudrait mans reconnaître leurs
compétences à eux est essentielle pour
éviter les coups de fatigue ou les
malaises le contenu de ce repas compte
moins que sa régularité
le plus important c'est de le prendre
tous les matins deux jours plus tard
anne valérie anime un autre atelier
autour du diabète cette fois devant un
autre public dans une maison de retraite
l'alimentation des abbés tic en fait
c'est l'alimentation équilibrée 1 par
excellence donc ne pas sauter de repas
faire trois ou quatre pas en fonction de
son rythme en général les personnes qui
font du diabète ne veulent absolument
pas se prendre un dessert parce que i
elle se prive de sucre hors pas
forcément que parfaitement en manger un
petit dessert au sein de repas
équilibrés
un atelier qui permet de casser les
idées reçues autour de cette maladie et
réconcilier les diabétiques avec
certains aliments de nombreux événements
ont été organisés pour cette semaine de
la nutrition qui se terminera jeudi avec
un grand jeu pour toute la famille